nascar is back in las vegas tonight a
weekend of racing gets underway at the
speedway
with some fans in the stands kate
houston looks at the valley's biggest
event since the pandemic began
tonight more than 10 thousand fans will
fill these stands behind me
and although there's health and safety
guidelines in place the speedway says
it will be a fun and engaging experience
for everybody here
sound nascar fans haven't heard in
person for many months
it's exciting we're ready to be back to
racing drivers will be competing in
front of a sold out crowd each night
drawing in fans from out of town
and right here in las vegas patrick
perniak set up an entire entertainment
area outside of his rv with tv's grills
and corn hole
to promote his business and enjoy
watching the races
last night people are out and about
they're they're walking around they're
riding their bikes and scooters you
wouldn't tell
there's anything different it's social
distancing at its best
fans will have to follow strict health
protocols while inside the speedway and
in the rv area
gary mckay has been coming to the races
for the past 20 years
as a lifelong fan he says it's worth it
to be back with his friends and family
great to come back see people here
because last night we met a bunch
over on the other side so we sat there
and partied with them you know they're
from california we're from utah and so
it's just
it's getting to be just one big family
like thing again like it used to be
the first race kicks off tonight at six
nascar says the drivers will be bringing
it up a notch knowing fans are back in
the stands
kate houston 8 news now